der durchschnittsdeutsche liste rund 30
minuten am tag bücher denn in wahrheit
wenn man auch andere digitale arten des
lesens mit einem pc dürfte da es
deutlich mehr sein dokumente und
tabellen in der arbeit kommentare auf
youtube jedes mal wenn man etwas
recherchiert auf twitter auf reddit beim
eames blogpost nachrichten whatsapp und
sogar ein computer spielen muss man
quests zu lesen ich habe lange gesucht
aber keine statistik gefunden wie viel
wir also wirklich lesen bei mir
persönlich sind es aber deutlich über
drei stunden reiner lesezeit jeden tag
das sind 21 stunden pro woche also 1095
stunden pro jahr umgerechnet 27 ganze 40
stunden arbeitswoche die ich nur mit
lesen verbringen was wäre denn jetzt
wenn ich diese zeit halbieren könnte
speed reading das ist die kunst des
schnellen wesens erfahrene spieler
erreichen damit bis zu 1000 wörter pro
minute also zum beispiel harry potter
und der stein der weisen in unter drei
stunden mit simplen techniken die man
teilweise in wenigen stunden lernen kann
sondern damit also seine
lesegeschwindigkeit verdoppeln können
wodurch ich jedes jahr 547 stunden oder
jeden tag eineinhalb stunden mehr
freizeit hätte und genau das finde ich
diese woche heraus wie schnell er nicht
das speed reading und wie geht das und
wie viel prozent kann ich dadurch meine
lesegeschwindigkeit erhöhen und schaffe
ich es dann endlich ein ganzes buch am
tag zu lesen somit er hier tatsächlich
wenn ich wirklich ein buch am tag lesen
könnte hätte ich in kürzester zeit die
anzahl an büchern die ich bisher immer
im gesamten leben gelesen habt
verdoppelt für die meisten würde das
bereits nach kürzester zeit ein treffen
für mich schon morgen unter dass hier
die beiden die einzigen bücher sind die
ich in meinem leben von anfang bis ende
durch gelesen hat könnt euch vielleicht
vorstellen dass sie nicht der schnellste
leser bin aber wie schnell genau finden
wir es raus und staat
[Musik]
stop 13 minuten und 6 sekunden haben
jetzt gebraucht für den zehn seiten
entspricht 157 wörtern pro sekunde das
ist relativ wenig aber mit welchen
tricks kann man das jetzt verbessern
schritt eins wenn ihr eure augen bewusst
um herbewegt zum beispiel eben beim
lesen werden sie sich abgehakt bewegen
man kann bewusst nicht einmal in die
ferne schauen und seine augen flüssig
von links nach rechts bewegen
unterbewusst geht das aber wenn die
augen etwas verfolgen wie zum beispiel
seinen finger und alleine diese
konstante geschwindigkeit ohne abrupte
stopps soll die lesegeschwindigkeit um
20 prozent steigern
mal schauen
[Musik]
ich komme gerade ein bisschen vorwiegend
wieder der zum ersten mal lesen lernt
und mit seinem finger nachvollziehen
muss aber wohl scheinbar wenn es einen
grund wieder hilft da hilft auch hier
auch hier stoppt ich jetzt mal die zeit
[Musik]
55 sagen wir 56 sekunden für diese eine
seite fast 320 wörter pro minute
das sind 40 prozent 40 schneller
okay was in extras schritt 2 in dem wir
in effizienz beseitigen denn obwohl
unser sichtfeld in dem ihr perfekt sehen
sehr sehr schmal ist sehen wir auch
rundherum noch relativ brauchbar beim
lesen fixieren die meisten von uns
jedoch jedes einzelne wort eines nach
dem anderen mann kann aber angeblich
auch jeweils links und rechts der zeile
ein zwei drei oder sogar vier wörter
auslassen er kennt sie aus dem
augenwinkel trotzdem und spart zeit als
hilfestellung dafür habe ich mir eine
begrenzung angezeichnet die mein blick
beim lesen nicht überschreiten darf man
schauen ob ich das überhaupt kann das
ist gar nicht so leicht das ist gar
nicht so leicht obwohl ich die sachen
die ruhe durchlesen kann bringt
automatisch mit einem auge direkt immer
wieder zwischen wörtern und wenn ich es
bewusst nicht wo dann fällt mir wirklich
schwer die einfach wirklich trotzdem
auch zu lesen und nicht einfach zu
überspringen
ich glaube es braucht ein bisschen übung
ich glaube das kann ich nicht machen ich
glaube da muss ich glaube das muss ich
erst noch mal bis zu trainieren
es gibt den ganzen mann versucht
[Musik]
doch demontierte sekunden also nochmal
ca 20 prozent schneller und insgesamt
zusammen dann 65 prozent schneller als
am anfang nur mit diesen beiden sachen
nicht schlecht schnitt 3 langsam wird es
schwer für mein gehirn bei der
geschwindigkeit hinterherzukommen das
liegt daran dass ich wie viele aber
nicht alle anderen auch jedes einzelne
wort bewusst in meinem kopf sprecher
dadurch kann ich da nicht viel schneller
lesen als ich aussprechen kann trotzdem
ist es jetzt an der zeit noch schneller
zu werden so schnell bis der teil in
meinem gehirn der gelesener inhalte
versteht abgestellt wird und ein anderer
aktiviert wird der das gelesene im
kopfkino umwandelt wie ein filmprojektor
das sagt zumindest muss er hier der
schnellste liga der welt hartberg
vorstellen kann ich mir das aber noch
nicht
also ich jetzt habe ich gefühlt die welt
habe nur angeschaut und nicht gelesen
oder nicht mehr verstanden schwierig das
was jetzt passiert erinnert mich an ein
video das ich vor einiger zeit gesehen
habe über jemanden ohne inneren monolog
es gibt menschen die tatsächlich nicht
aktiv mit wörtern im kopf denken indem
man eben mit sich selbst redet nur in
gedanken so wie ich mein ganzes leben
bei alle zum beispiel ist das etwas
anders sie liest unglaublich gerne aber
sie denkt sich nicht jedes einzelne
gelesene wort nach dem anderen wie ich
das immer für normal gehalten habe aber
wie macht sie erst dann wie kann man
lesen ohne dabei zu denken
aber das muss nicht das merkst du ja zum
beispiel lesen kannst du musst das nicht
verbalisieren diese entdeckung mache ich
hier gerade zum ersten mal und das ist
mir zufällig beim lesen auf gefallen
wodurch ich auf die idee gekommen bin
ali zu fragen wie das bei ihr ist wenn
ich bei diesem extrem schnellen lesen
bei dem ein analytischer verstanden
sowieso nicht mitkommt eben diesen
verstand entspanne wie bei einer
meditation damit er eben nicht jedes
wort in gedanken ausspricht dann nehme
ich die wörter trotzdem war und saugen
sie auf und das
geht deutlich schneller irgendwie
verstehe ich den inhalt trotzdem aber
eigentlich macht es auch sinn man kann
ja auch einen stein anschauen ohne sich
zu denken
stein und erkennen den trotzdem wie ich
erst später herausgefunden habe hat das
nicht mal unbedingt etwas damit zu tun
dass alle keinen inneren monolog hat
lesen ohne innere stimme ist scheinbar
eine sache die jeder trainieren kann das
ja kennt das wenn euch mit video zu
langweilig ist und jetzt einfach auf
doppelter geschwindigkeit anhört und
dann plötzlich unterhaltungs nicht
abgehen kann so kommen wie das gelaufen
ist entwickelt sich einfach viel
schneller und pro minute passiert
einfach mehr unterricht ist es halt auch
irgendwie spannende an oder wenn man
schneller lesen kann ich merke aber auch
dass die sachen also wörter die ich gut
kenne ganz normale wörter mit dem man
auch redet immer sich gar nicht drüber
nachdenken die gehen direkt sagt aber
diese wörter die ich nicht täglich
benutzen oder die mehr komplett neu sind
wie zum beispiel die foto me oder ein
triumphales crescenti oder komplette
eigennamen wie zb die als guten von
trier
das muss ich einfach wirklich ein
buchstabe lesen und das dann ganz
schwierig dann wieder zu beschleunigen
und dann wieder mal einzelne wörter
stehen zu bleiben das fällt mir finde
ich schwieriger wenn ich das mit dem
finger mache deswegen weil ich den
finger weglassen mit dieser methode
schaffte ich jetzt also 340 wörter pro
minute fast 220 mehr als ganz am anfang
doppelt so schnell heftig ich war nie
ein guter leser stunden vergehen in
denen ich das speed reading überfalls
man das nun ja zu nennen kann denn für
mich ist es eine völlig neue art text
fahrt zunehmen aber wieviel des
gelesenen bleibt auch wirklich hängen wo
zu schnell lesen wenn man nachdem man
das buch geschlossen hat bereits alles
vergessen hat extra dafür gibt es einen
test bei dem ich nicht nur meine
lesegeschwindigkeit ein letztes mal auf
den prüfstand stellen werde sondern am
ende auch fragen gestellt bekommen mit
denen überprüft wird wie gut ich den
text auch verstehe denn wenn ich gar
nicht akzeptabel abschneide war alles
umsonst
der test funktioniert so dass man die
zahl stoppt dann ein textabschnitt wie
ist dann eine frage beantwortet zum
textinhalt und dann weiter machen davon
gibt es sechs abschnitte und jedes mal
wenn man nicht fragen beantwortet wird
die zeit nicht weiter gezählt und 3 2 1
verstopft was war in dem haus im
originalzustand nicht vorhanden
das ist jetzt direkt mit keine ahnung
weil es nicht weitergeht
wo sollte laut plan der haupteingang des
hauses zahlen das sind fragen das ist
echt krass dass ich so richtig keine
detailfragen sind es aufpassen
weiter geht's
wie wurde das erste mal verändert das
weiß ich sogar doppelt so groß gemacht
wie viele bedienstete hatte der
geistliche marchand dreistellung den
verführte karl marx der handel mit
seiner haushälterin warum hörten die
meisten gegnerinnen mit 35 jahren
aufzuarbeiten haben ich glaube dass so
schnell ich glaube dass recht und 350
das ist strong das ist echt krass die
frage wie viele fragen sich jetzt
richtig über den ersten fall bin ich
überhaupt nicht mitgekommen aber danach
hatte ich ein bisschen besser aufgepasst
und die waren auch sein easy hier sind
die lösungen für drei große verdoppelt
jack frage 4 haushälterin und die heirat
weil sie ja vier von sechs fragen
richtig und ich das mal in den pool
stucco gesehen habe ist es schon gut
wenn man einfach das meiste versteht und
das habe ich ja vier von sechs fragen
mit dem experiment wollte ich eben auch
ein bisschen herausfinden ob das
wirklich realistisch ist ein buch an
einem tag zu lesen weil das ist etwas
was ich mir nie vorstellen konnte dieses
buch mit 128.000 wörtern sind 410 seiten
könnte ich jetzt mit der geschwindigkeit
in sechs stunden durchlesen was man halt
wirklich am nachmittag aber mal machen
kann dir so ein dünneres buch wie per
anhalter durch die galaxis das kann
nicht so einfach in drei vier stunden an
dem faden durch weil ich das jeden tag
machen wir uns natürlich ein anderes
thema wahrscheinlich nicht ich hoffe
euch hat das video gefallen ich mache
übrigens ja jede woche eine ist es
selbst experimente also wenn ihr da kann
es mal verpassen möchte jetzt gerne
diesen kanal bereite mich auf diese
reise und dann sehen uns beim nächsten
mal mit macht's gut
[Musik]
in der 78